don't get pets as presence once again
rochford District Council is supporting
the RSPCA's and your message to the
public herbed urging them to spare a
thought for animals this Christmas by
not buying pets as presents or
abandoning them over the festive period
each year the rspca and other animal
welfare organizations are inundated with
pets that are abandoned dumped or left
to fend for themselves while their
owners go away in addition to this
rescue centers also have to deal with
people handing in animals that have been
given as unwanted gifts during the past
year there have been many articles in
the newspapers about pets being
abandoned or handed over to rehoming
centres as well as the numerous cats and
dogs that are looking for homes horse
welfare charities have reported a rise
in the number of horses that have been
abandoned or handed over to them which
has left these animal welfare
organizations struggling to cover the
cost of caring for them so if I have to
take into account the initial cost and
ongoing expenses of owning an animal you
still want to get one why not leave
getting your pet until the new year when
all the Christmas excitement has died
down this way you'll have time to help
your new pet settle in better still
there are many loveable unwanted or
abandoned animals being cared for by
animal welfare organizations so why not
consider giving one of these animals a
new home the rspca silver awards the
council has once again been awarded the
RSPCA's silver stray dogs footprint and
the silver animal welfare principles
footprint a stray dog footprint
recognizes the council's work in
providing a stray dog service that
protects both animal welfare and public
safety the animal welfare principles
footprint recognizes the council's work
on its animal welfare Charter the animal
welfare Charter can be viewed on the
council's website
or if you'd like a hard copy contact the
animal welfare officer on 0 1 702 3180
57 can you help the Essex horse and pony
protection society eh PPS with its
winter hay appeal because the sanctuary
is located on a site of special
scientific interest grazing is severely
restricted between october and april
every year the horses and ponies they
rescue chomp their way through 30 bales
of hay a day that's 210 bales a week
which costs over 1,000 pounds they need
contributions to help them behave the
ponies and horses they rescue for more
details on how you can help contact 0126
858 4603 or email administrator at eh
PPS org dot uk' can you foster cats with
the cold weather coming we look forward
to living in warm houses but life is
tough for many stray cats during the
summer a lot of stray cats are fine
people are happy to feed them and watch
them laze around in their gardens but
that all changes come the winter
Rayleigh cats protection urgently need
to get these cats into a safe warm and
secure place so they don't have to eat
frozen food shiver in the cold and get
soaked in the rain they desperately need
your help could you become one of their
foster errs they'll provide food cat
litter bowls and pay any veterinary
costs you just need a spare room and
time to give them a care and attention
for homing information call 0126 8750
8314 fostering 0126 879 4648 or visit w
wh org UK
or could you help abandoned dogs in the
district the Friends of abandoned dogs
at acres way are also always looking for
homes for the many abandoned dogs in
their care and whatever the time of year
the dogs they care for still need
feeding the kennels are always very
grateful for any donations from members
of the public of dog food or treats to
help feed their charges especially over
the Christmas period they would also
welcome any donations of blankets or
towels to keep the dogs warm and dry
during the damp wintery days if you're
interested in finding out more or
helping the Friends of abandoned dogs
you can contact the kennels on 01 268
double 7040 to you can also take your
donations direct to then at acres way
kennels great birches Road thundersley
rochford score strategy inspector says
plan for the district's future is sound
watch the district councils plan for the
future development of the district the
poor strategy has been approved by the
government inspector conducting the
examination the core strategy sets out
the key planning policies for the
district and will determine how the area
will develop over the next 15 years and
beyond it addresses issues such as the
location and type of new housing sites
for employment development strategic
infrastructure requirements and town
center in Harmons nents to name but a
few it also introduces a number of
measures to ensure the protection of the
district's environment following
extensive community involvement
appraisal and evidence gathering the
council's of greed core strategy was
submitted to the government for
examination in January 2010 to determine
whether the strategy was sound and
legally compliant the council had
expected the results of the examination
to be issued within six months the usual
time for the government to consider such
plans however as a result of the change
in government amendments to national
policy and legal challenges against the
secretary of state for communities and
local government the examination process
was significantly delayed the planning
inspectorate has now issued its report
on the core strategy and found it to be
sound the core strategy ensures the vast
majority of the district's greenbelt is
protected from development directing
housing and employment to the most
appropriate locations it will also
ensure new development is built to high
environmental standards meets the needs
of the local community and is
accompanied by Lana the cloth strategy
covers a diverse range of issues from
protecting environmentally sensitive
areas and providing new recreational
spaces to setting out framework for
economic growth in the district
including tell centre enhancements and
development around london Southend
Airport
the inspectors report will be presented
to the council on the 13th of december
for consideration and subject to
approval by the council formal adoption
adoption of the core strategy will mean
locations for future development are
confirmed the council is now progressing
work on related policy documents this
will include the allocations development
plan document which will set out the
precise boundaries of the sites to be
developed within the general locations
now confirmed by the core strategy and
the development management development
plan document which will provide
detailed policies events to which
planning applications will be determined
look for opportunities to have your say
on these in the new year for further
details interview information on the
core strategy visit our website w WAW k
as the days get shorter and the weather
gets colder the council has put together
a few handy heads about how you and your
family can prepare for winter protect
your home check that pipes are
adequately lagged check that you've
ordered your winter heating fuel check
that you know where your stop tap is
located find out if you're entitled to
grants and subsidies for home heating
and insulation traveling before you
travel check the winter weather forecast
at the Met Office's winter weather
portal check that your vehicle is ready
for winter check that you know where to
find traffic and travel information
check local and national weather
forecasts and keep up to date with the
latest warnings technically have an
emergency kit available in your car
communities check that you know who
might need helping your community area
in really bad weather sign up for
weather warnings on the Met Office
website and check whether you're at risk
of flooding and sign up for free flood
warnings by visiting the environment
agency's website and here are some
useful websites for you ww-what org dot
uk' ww directgov UK www Met Office gov
UK www environment hyphen agency dot-gov
UK and www 6 govt UK forward slash
winter and don't forget to get the jab
that could save your life it's the time
of year when we see many people
suffering from flu-like illness like
every winter the flu viruses circulate
and attack people with a weak immune
system and those suffering from other
long-term conditions like asthma and
diabetes nationally during the 2009
winter season more people died from
influenza and pneumonia than those who
died with breast or prostate cancer
the NHS in south essex is urging people
at risk of flu to get protected and have
the vaccine for groups have been
identified as being most at-risk
pregnant women people with long-term
conditions and serious illness that make
their immune system weak for example
cancer asthma diabetes heart disease and
neurological illnesses carers who look
after vulnerable people and people over
65 years the head of public health for
NHS southeast Essex Margaret Gray said
flu is different from getting a cold and
the effects of seasonal flu are often
underestimated some people at more at
risk from flu and need the vaccine
because they're not able to fight off
flu as easily as others it can often
result in more serious complications
which require hospital treatment and the
figures from last winter show that
sometimes there can be devastating
consequences of death this can be
prevented by having the vaccine which is
being provided free to eligible people
at GP surgeries across south essex for
people with long term conditions carers
those over 65 and pregnant women
associate director of public health at
NHS south west essex dr. aaron patel
added flu is a highly infectious illness
caused by viruses we now have a safe
effective vaccine vaccine for the
viruses that will circulate this winter
it's important that those at risk
protect themselves every year and
getting the free job helps protect them
and their loved ones there are
additional ways people can protect
themselves and those around them good
hand hygiene they catch it vinit kill it
technique reduces the spread of germs
this means carrying tissues covering
coughs and sneezes with a tissue
disposing of the tissue after one use
and cleaning hands as soon as possible
with soap and water or an alcohol hand
gel people in the at-risk groups can get
their free flu vaccine by contacting
their
GP practice for more information visit
www.pay